eleven all right Tristan how would you
advise curbing addiction to our phones
do you do you use apps well that's of
course you use it yes sir um one thing
I've tried recently if you make your
phone greyscale actually it takes that
one grayscale so to take the color out
of your screen so to go to the setting
if you can take the color out for me I
notice it actually makes a big
difference in how addicted I am oh just
because the colorful rewards are like
reinforcing this this system of I mean
the red the red circle for example
that's part of this addictive element so
when you take that out turn off
notifications is very simple I highly
recommend that but grayscale actually
for me it's all quite a bit Jesus people
are such [ __ ] Chimchar
evolution one we know all the way up ad
them friggin manipul
depressing gym we still advocate a
third-party candidate for president her
system needs something different this
thing isn't working
I actually I thought Ben Sasse was a
really really good guest for you he's
like one of the few people I like him
and there that's talking differently
thinking differently and I think like
listen that the politics don't thinking
we're Trump could have been good was it
the place needed something big it needed
an earthquake in Washington is basically
uncover Noble except for when you have
all party rule and so the only time
anything's gotten done in the last 12
years is the two years when Bush had all
party rule two years when Obama had all
party rule and now Republicans are
blowing it because I have all Republican
rule but they're not actually doing much
with it and so I think that if something
doesn't change because it's not just at
repetitiveness the addiction it's the
fact that what Facebook and social media
has done is it this gives you a bunch of
people that will say whatever dumb thing
you say that's great day it's great I
got a thousand fans a thousand flowers I
get a more incentive to be at home as
you can possibly feel so really turning
all human beings into rats I mean right
nobody you're right I mean in the old
days or the John Birch Society had to go
door to door with pamphlets and get
people to come to your blend meeting or
whatever and right right now you just
follow the red button Yeah right okay
will trump block call me from testifying
Kenny look Wiggly they can he's
testifying Thursday right of the date
legally they can try to throw them
pétomane
so that executive privilege but if he
does now you know we've been wrong a
thousand times about the politics of
Donald Trump but if he does that I think
there's a nuclear explosion on the hill
and I think even the Republicans at that
point say this is unacceptable Jim Comey
needs to tell a story in public or
electonic Trump's credibility goes you
tell you tonight they're seriously
thinking about executive privilege for
you the problem is I call me can just go
hold a press conference you might keep
him out of testifying he's a free man
you speak and and well he I mean what do
we expect I like I cannot wait for this
litter very motivated and held inside of
the story I mean right is this is his
big moment right and I think he already
has I mean to great extent he's already
told the story this is what Donald Trump
told me to do I wrote memos that at the
contemporaneous memos that said here's
what he told me that's the story he's
going to reiterate that story at a
little bit texture but we already know
it so you're going to say it again it's
you're going to call it from his over
there Ziegler actually bring the memos
romanticism I think we shed more memos I
want him to bring them what did you
think Rebecca of the recent tension in
the Democratic Party over whether every
supported candidate should have the same
pro-choice position oh I think that we
have this conversation every single time
a Democrat loses and that the
conversation I mean this is this was the
the thing we did after the 2004 election
Rahm Emanuel decided we could get the
house by ditching abortion and ditching
reproductive rights as a requirement now
there are lots of issues that you know
we could bring right-leaning Americans
in on if we just jettison them but it
always seems to be reproductive rights
that off not exclusively the men but
often the men who leave the Democratic
Party or want to re-envision it that's
the first thing they imagine we can go
now it's also based on really faulty
polling it used to be they used to poll
America one way and say do you believe
in abortion and half the people said yes
and half the people said no and it was
like oh we're rebek we just divided but
what there has been in the past couple
years and I recommend that these guys
actually look at these polls and new
ways of doing polls where you first ask
are you personally in favor of abortion
and then you get people saying no and
then the follow-up is but do you want
regulated and when you ask the questions
like that you get seven out of ten who
wants legal abortion who want some
measure of access to abortion even in
Kansas even in Nebraska that there is
really extensive polling on that and
none of these guys seem to read this is
actually one of the more popular I've
seen Republican politicians be
contradictory in the same sentence
I saw hurt member Herman Cain Herman
came to zest about they was hysterical
it was like the government should not be
in our lives unless it's my daughter
right right right
you know Dan Quayle hasn't the same way
it would be a choice that we make of the
family right yes all right which world
leader now best represents liberal
values well apparently we've been a big
brouhaha with Germany because Angela
Merkel did not kiss his ass so Germany
very bad very bad that's that's where we
are if you know you do the flattery bit
with him very bad your country's very
bad but it does look like she's you know
the leader of the free world no doubt
appeared Oh Trudeau well not it is a
small not okay you're saying Iowa yeah
no hey I mean her neighbor I love Canada
but you know it's it's not it but he's
been good on a pole bungee and I like
the tweet he sent out about that climate
change and yeah they'd been into
Rebecca's point earlier he said
specifically we regret that the federal
government is no longer there basically
saying everybody else mayors governors
corporations come work with us
having Canada maybe too nice to be nice
I'm our Germany has a history of being a
little yeah well it will now they've
channeled it in a better direction that
yeah
let's hope sup know well we know they
have come on at least for now
Elliott you think that more underdog
Democratic candidates in traditionally
red districts can win like Christine
Pellegrino did in Long Island last month
absolutely why because the the energy in
the Democratic base is real look I've
never believed when a candidate says I'm
going to get people to the polls who
haven't voted before I said okay you're
a loser because that's not going to
happen right now I actually think that
can happen the energy out there is
palpable the desire to get rid of Trump
to get rid of Paul Ryan to get rid of
Mitch McConnell there's no question in
my mind we can actually win big in 18 we
don't yeah it's all oh yeah
but you know as I was saying a minute
ago we haven't done that it hasn't
really happened because we we need the
backbone that you were articulating I
mean I'm the no wimpiness just go out
and fight and also what I was asking the
senator from Nebraska about why are
these places in the country Montana you
know you can assault somebody the day
before the election Nebraska where I
just cannot imagine under any
circumstance the Democrat winning why
are Democrats that where I do think they
actually think they would rather elect a
Russian then it they think the Russians
are less of a threat than Democrats and
liberals I really think half the country
believes that part of it is and I hate I
hate to blame the media so I'm not going
to blame them but I think part of this
20 to 30 years of the media being so
conservative in certain parts of the
country that the Democratic view doesn't
get heard really is it's so funny
because they would say there's the made
aetiology thank you and Jim they just
with me you're in the media but that's
muggy
I mean Montana they elected a Democrat I
think that right so if they are
electable you know Democrat could win
but it does go down to and this is a big
choice if people talk about 18 into the
latter 2006 rahm emanuel did have that
strategy of trying to find people that
fit in individual districts we had a lot
of moderate democrats that helped win
back the house the question this time is
when you look there's fewer seats that
are authentically winnable now than
there would have been 12 years ago
because of redistricting because we all
moved away from people we don't like
their eighties we move next to people
that we do the question is can you then
find candidates that fit those districts
and that's still very much an open
question right now
for Democrats it would be the thing if
you talk to rob him on your show he
would say worries him the most right now
but he worries that the party will
reject people that could win in those
seats okay Thank You panel very
entertaining thank you
[Applause]